je m'appelle d'afir la même songé 17 ans
et demi et je suis né par gestation pour
autrui aux états unis
[Musique]
j'ai mon père qui est français ma mère
qui est italienne
mes parents ont eu recours à une
gestatrice aux états unis ce qui fait
que je suis je suis né en californie et
en plus on a eu une donatrice de vos
sites donc aide qui est franco
vietnamienne on connaissait déjà madonna
tu ris de veau si c'était une amie à ma
mère la gestatrice on a rencontré par le
biais d'une association j'étais pas des
personnes que je pourrais lui dire que
je considère que ma famille ces décès
des personnes qui sont indéniablement
importante pour moi puisque je suis un
peu negras elle donc c'est cool mais il
n'y a pas vraiment à ce vraiment ça un
lien j'ai pas ce que je fais jamais je
regarderai majesté triste et je me dirai
à c'est peut-être ma mère gnagnagna
comme certains pour enfin comme certains
ont cette idée qu'il faut absolument que
c'est la personne qui accouchent qui est
la mère ce fait un nom enfin la
gestatrice vous les accepte pas ce rôle
de mère moi non plus et on s'est toutes
les deux que c'est pas qu'on n'a pas
cette relation entre nous
[Musique]
on réunit en un seul débat de deux
questions très importantes
comment faut-il légaliser la gpa mais de
plus important je pense c'est comment on
s'occupe des enfants qui naissent par
gpa quoi qu'il arrive enfin c'est pas
une question hypothétique on est
vraiment on existe vraiment et c'est ça
je pense qu'ils équipe qui apparaît pas
assez aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a tendance
à trop oublier qu'il s'agit vraiment eu
de vraie vie quand on fait ce soi disant
débat quoi enfin mon existence devrait
pas être devrait pas être un débat en
fait on a un truc un peu théorique un
peu un concept mais pas vraiment réel
donc et après c'est compréhensible parce
que les enfants nés par gpa
la plupart ils sont quand même assez
jeune donc moi j'ai 17ans année j'ai la
possibilité d'être de parler et de
montrer qu'on est banon n'est pas que un
concept ou un mot qu'on sur lequel on
peut venir coller toutes les étiquettes
qu'on veut et on n'est pas des
marchandises on n'est pas des objets des
fois ça se passe pas forcément de façon
très éthique et s'est passé parce qu'on
veut nous c'est pas quand on dit qu'on
veut légaliser la gpa on dit pas qu'on
veut absolument ont transformé des gens
des femmes en usine ou je sais pas quoi
au contraire fin non moi en tant que
femme en tant qu'enfant nés par gpa
ça serait mon cauchemar que ça devienne
comme ça non au contraire je pense que
non seulement égalisant là j'ai pas et
en france eh bien on pourrait ça
permettrait au moins d'encadrer ça et de
le rendre de prôner un contact et la
relation et des liens humains
il ya des gens qui voudraient justement
bas que ça soit un poids pesant qui
voudrait que les enfants nés par gpa à
est absolument mal et ressentent un mal
être et donc banon heureuse
heureusement ça m'empêche pas d'être
super contente d abord me
ma famille d'aller au lycée de passer
mon bac tout ça donc c'est vraiment pas
quelque chose qui m'affecte
psychologiquement ou qui me fait sentir
mal